well i've said it before and i'll say it
again everything's coming up mushrooms
it's revolutionizing food and now
fashion purewow reports that high
fashion brand hermes has designed its
first bag made of mushroom leather
that's right they're working with mica
works a company that uses mycelium which
is the roots of the mushroom to make
alternative leather it looks like
leather and it feels like leather but
it's more eco-friendly and it uses less
water and energy to produce wow
this leather alternative is coming to
fashion furniture and even seats in your
car so you can vroom vroom on your
mushroom oh that's cute stella mccartney
also just um
trademarked milo and she'll be working
exclusively with that material moving
forward and so i'm so grateful it is the
future and here we are i love it this is
so positive i think it's fascinating i
don't understand how it works but i want
to know more
all right we got to um you know we love
a taste test here at the desk and today
we got a big one it's a bold new snack
women's health reports model ashley
graham says she's got the perfect
surprising snack combination created by
her two-year-old son listen to this it's
spicy tortilla chips dipped in crunchy
peanut butter okay
uh sound good or no what do you think
well we're gonna give it a taste right
here we have it right here thank you
drew of course my love okay so these are
this is a spicy these are spicy chips
okay all right and you're gonna dip it
in the peanut butter i'm sativating
right
i actually think this might be great
we also have an audience member tasting
say hi to florence foreign
all right grab this chip okay and dip it
in the crunchy peanut butter lauren
really spicy one yeah good all that i'm
excited to hear what you think okay
give it a try
i have so many thoughts
it tastes a lot of peanut butter yeah
and now it takes a little spice
it's not bad
it's not bad i thought it was gonna be
uh
it's not bad it's good yeah what was
that word again was it
yeah you're my kind of woman no no no i
battle all the time
you know what's giving me is like when
you have thai food like a pad thai or
something there's peanuts in the spice
you know what i'm talking about right
here florence okay how many stars you
give it out of five i'll give it four
i'm not a five-star person i never give
it anybody five stars sorry but
four stars is good i mean i would eat
this four stars from florence i got five
i'm gonna go all five
[Music]
you